au
printemps 2005 devant les caméras du
monde entier mikhaïl khodorkovski prend
le chemin de la prison
deux ans auparavant il était encore
l'homme le plus riche de russie à la
tête de la plus grande compagnie
pétrolière du pays il pesait alors près
de 15 milliards de dollars
les prix de l'or noir flambait les
profits sans voler mais pour le jeune
milliardaire de 40 ans cela ne suffisait
pas
mais lorsqu'il y avait d'autres
ambitions des ambitions politiques
c'est en février 2003 que les ennuis ont
commencé
comme chaque année vladimir poutine
réunis tôt kremlin ce que l'on nomme en
russie les oligarques pétrole aluminium
gaz il contrôlera un seul l'essentiel
des richesses du pays
alors que ce qui le roi du pétrole
peaufine son intervention une
dénonciation en règle de la corruption
qui sévit au sommet de l'état il accuse
nommément des hauts fonctionnaires
proches de poutine dont le président de
rosneft une autre compagnie pétrolière
il s'agit ici de corruption d'agents de
l'état
la corruption atteint dans notre pays la
somme de 30 milliards de dollars
ces dix tous pour sens de notre produit
intérieur brut
j'ai malheureusement la population est
très sceptique quant à la volonté de
l'état de combattre la corruption
certaines compagnies pétrolières comme
par exemple ioukos ont aujourd'hui de
bonnes réserves
comment elle et ont obtenu on peut en
discuter ici il veut aussi parler du
paiement des impôts ou plutôt de la
fraude fiscale vous comprenez alors je
renvoie la balle dans
un petit coup de griffe devant la presse
et plusieurs millions de téléspectateurs
au quotidien commerçante le chroniqueur
du kremlin andreï kolesnikov et de ses
journalistes qui font assaut de prudence
n'est inféodé au pouvoir ni critique
frontale cette réunion il en avait
décrit tous les ressorts l'habituel
déférence des oligarques à l'égard du
président et l'impertinence de
khodorkovski
je voyais dans la salle et comment tous
ses collègues casillas est même tarif se
jeter des regards une chute brych à
l'égard ces infortunés oligarques ils se
regardaient en désignant de la tête
rôdeur cost income pour dire mais il est
suicidaire celui-là
- pau ils ont tous sursauté c'est pour
tout cela les impôts c'est un cauchemar
d'un cauchemar quand poutine te regarde
et demande alors et des impôts et bien
autour de la table il n'y en a b g et si
sur le plan fiscal car on pouvait se
dire en règle ni moins
mais ces histoires d'impôt n'était pas
chose nouvelle et n'inquiétait pas
mireille kasyanov alors premier ministre
car à l'époque khodorkovski était un
oligarque comme les autres loyal et
obéissants du moins en apparence
les propos de radars construit était
tout à fait normaux
faire dans le pays était normal qu'en
2003 c'est le pic de la confiance entre
le pouvoir et les milieux d'affaires
et les participants à cette table ronde
moi y compris nous n'avons pas accordé
d'attention particulière à cette petite
passe d'armes entre le président et
redore cops qui
à l'époque le jeune milliardaire avait
ses entrées au kremlin au sein même de
l'administration présidentielle
alexandre they merco proche de
khodorkovski participait aux discussions
il est aujourd'hui réfugié à londres
poursuivi par la justice russe
ancien haut fonctionnaire
c'est lui qui à ioukos était chargé de
soigner les relations avec le kremlin
nous avons demandé conseil à vau-l'eau
chine à l'époque chef de
l'administration présidentielle
nous avons aussi demandé à kasyanov le
premier ministre joue
volochine a dit allez-y soulevé le
problème que le président donne ses
instructions sur la question
et volochine a donné l'ordre à la télé
de montrer ce passage
toute la réunion n'a pas été montrée
c'est seulement ce passage qui a été
diffusée sur les écrans les éditeurs et
si volochine avait bien préparé le
président celui ci aurait réagi
différemment
mais poutine a pour principe de défendre
les siens coop c'est pour cela qu'il a
réagi aussi vivement il n'abandonne pas
ses
affaires aurait certainement pu en
rester là
khodorkovski n'est pas un oligarque
comme les autres il est le premier
d'entre eux à s'être pris de passion
pour son pays sa toute jeune fondation
russie ouverte investi depuis un an dans
l'éducation l'internet le développement
la société civile
au north cove qui parcourt le pays donne
des conférences rencontres les
journalistes et commence à tenir de
drôles de propos
le problème aujourd'hui dans le pays
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de société civile
elle est complètement absente chez nous
quand on dit c'est bien ça veut dire
c'est bien pour l'état
on parle de la position de l'état la
proche de l'état l'intérêt de l'état
c'est complètement ridicule c'est
n'importe quoi
d'où notre travail auprès des enfants
nous leur enseignons ce que sont la
démocratie et les valeurs libérales et
comment vivre avec
tout un programme très politique et rose
lorkowski ne se contente pas de labourer
le champ social ils financent les partis
politiques de gauche et de droite
certains hauts responsables de ioukos se
sont même fait élire à la douma
l'assemblée nationale russe
alexey qu'honda au rove ancien général
du kgb députés étaient chargés
d'analyser pour ioukos le risque
politique à la douma c'est le lobbying
qu'il pratiquait je tombe au vote
c'était pour qu'en russie il y est une
opposition réelle
et que l'état compte avec cette
opposition
lui et moi et tout ce qui l'entouré
on sait qu'il fallait une russie
différentes
une russie démocratique
transparente et ouverte
qui est notre compagnie commencez à
avoir beaucoup d'influencé à la douma
et lui même rodolphe qui devenait de
plus en plus indépendants
une figure indépendante qui développe un
réseau de soutien en russie et à
l'étranger
products qui ne cache pas son attrait
pour les etats-unis une position
pourtant impopulaire dans la russie de
vladimir poutine
si on ne se met pas d'accord
prochainement avec les américains en
tant que partenaire
pour nous c'est la fin
aucune percée aujourd'hui n'est possible
pour nous sans intégration dans
l'économie mondiale et en particulier
avec les américains
souci de l'état ou intérêts personnels
en tout cas ioukos héros darcos qui
entame des négociations avec dow major
américaine chevron et exxon pour céder
40 % de la compagnie russe soit la
bagatelle d'environ 20 milliards de
dollars
il restait seulement un mois avant que
l'on procède à la fusion avec l'une des
deux compagnies ça représente un pas
important
la plus grande compagnie pétrolière
faisait un bond en avant et devenait
tout à fait incontrôlable mais pas trop
ioukos incontrôlable pour leur coach qui
à la tête d'un magot tout en liquidités
le jeune milliardaire ne cache pas que
pour lui commencera bientôt une nouvelle
carrière des testings gardiste et je
quitterai mes fonctions à ioukos en 2007
je lis ici et là dans la presse que je
me destine à devenir gouverneur ou autre
chose ou chine savez je suis réaliste je
vois bien comment la société russe
considère les hommes d'affaires
importants les pétroliers comme moi mais
c'est pas grave ni tu votes c'est normal
c'est normal chacun sa croix
2007 c'est l'année qui précède
l'élection présidentielle russe et
rôdeur causes qui ne fait rien pour
rassurer ceux qui au kremlin ne veulent
pas d'une opposition indépendante
ioukos a commencé à parler de fusion
avec exxon ou chevron poutine a invité
roland koch qui a sa datcha pour une
discussion assez sérieuse
poutine c'est un militaire il a mis
devant l'alternative soit tu fais du
business soit tu fais d'un politique
avec toutes les conséquences que cela
peut entraîner
et qu'a répondu croire que ce qu'ils
font que ce qui a répondu je continuerai
à vivre selon les principes
et c'est à la douma l'assemblée russe
que l'affrontement se déplace
comme pour tous les autres oligarques le
lobby pétrolier de rôdeur cove qui
défend ses intérêts avec succès au début
de l'été 2003 ils parviennent à bloquer
un nouvel impôt au grand dam du kremlin
egor gaïdar ancien premier ministre les
spécialistes de la question fiscale a
été le témoin de cette lutte de clans
ce n'était pas une question d'argent
il s'agissait plutôt de montrer qui
était le plus fort et haut
et tous l'avez compris et au kremlin et
chez les pétroliers
je leur est vivement conseillé nice
tenait à ceux du secteur pétrolier
peuple et pointez vous n'allez pas au
conflit pour ces peccadilles pokemouche
top c'est un gant jeté à la figure du
pouvoir
egor gaïdar n'a pas été écouté la loi a
été repoussé
deux semaines plus tard anton lebedev le
bras droit de robert costes qui est
arrêté la machine judiciaire est en
marche elle si le maintenant le jeune
oligarque
s'il s'agit soit de me faire partir
soit il de me mettre en prison alors
qu'on me jette en prison parce qu'il est
hors de question que je devienne un
réfugié politique
crowder cove qui ne veut pas ressembler
à ces oligarques exilé au début de l'ère
poutine à londres ou à jérusalem lui
veut braver le pouvoir jusqu'au bout
octobre 2003 c'est à son tour de
connaître les geôles russes il est
accusé de fraude fiscale et
d'escroquerie le verdict est sans appel
8 ans de prison et ce ne sont pas les
manifestations de soutien qui font plier
le pouvoir russe
chez poutine il y a une approche très
guerrière une séparation entre les
nôtres et les autres
c'est une image en noir et blanc tu es
avec moi est contre moi nature de ce
côté là de la barricade ou de l'autre je
crois que pour goûter à un moment donné
d'un couvreur quevilly est devenu un
trader
depuis son arrivée au kremlin vladimir
poutine n'a eu de cesse de consolider ce
qu'il appelle la verticale du pouvoir
une remise en ordre autoritaire du pays
après le désordre des années dit il
[Applaudissements]
ce que l'on appelle les oligarques ont
profité des difficultés économiques et
législative du pays au moment de sa
transition pour amasser des milliards au
détriment de l'intérêt national
et du peuple russe
et tout cela de manière illégale vix
causes qui prend la tête de ioukos au
nahd bosco 28 soit bronze nicole il
fallait créer une coalition politique
pour déloger les directeurs rouge de
leur poche mitch et janis d'où il volé
l'argent
protégé par des bandits
au togo c'était une mauvaise méthode
mais elle s'est révélée efficace
pour résultat
pur souche dot essayer de trouver la
bonne méthode quand dans le pays la
production de pétrole est tombé à 60
millions de tonnes par an et que votre
budget est dépendant de ses revenus
pétroliers c'est bien sûr intéressant
d'utiliser ces bombes ans chez soi dans
la cuisine ou subis
et la production repart au prix de
licenciements massifs et de
restructuration
en quelques années du cause devient la
première compagnie pétrolière du pays 20
% de la production russe et près de cent
mille employés et tous les moyens sont
bons pour augmenter les profits échapper
à l'impôt filiales offshore astuce
juridique pour contourner une
législation encore balbutiante ce sont
ces pratiques que la justice russe a
retenu pour condamner roller cause ce
qui
à l'époque il y avait ce que l'on
appelle des brèches fiscale dans notre
législation
notre gouvernement réussit à convaincre
l'assemblée nationale de les supprimer
mais nous n'y sommes pas revenus qu'en
décembre 2003
donc les pratiques de hugh cause il est
formellement légal ces brèches
j'existais
ça fait comme toutes les autres
compagnies russes j'insiste bien toutes
les compagnies pétrolières gazières
autres l ont purement et simplement
profiter de ces brèches
mais la faire re darcos qui s'est aussi
le miroir de la russie des années 90
celle des règlements de compte et des
meurtres commandités
assassinat d'un maire en conflit ouvert
avec ioukos attentats commis contre un
partenaire qui crient à l'escroquerie
ces accusations ressurgissent
opportunément et la justice russe trouve
un coupable le chef du service de
sécurité de ioukos condamné pour meurtre
à 25 ans de prison
à l'époque presque toutes les compagnies
pétrolières étaient aux mains de ben 10
c'est est eux qui contrôlait les flux
financiers de la compagnie comme b
alors si quelqu'un s'avisait de
revendiquer le contrôle légal de
l'entreprise gazière ou pétrolière où tu
de poule où il courait le risque de
prendre une balle dans la tempe et de
voir sa famille prise en otage tieto
soumet le squad ceux qui ont réussi à
vaincre ces bandits et à rétablir une
direction normal ceux là sont devenu
multimilliardaire d'un seul coup
bousculade
mais qu'elle redore cove qui fait partie
de cette catégorie
oh pour arriver à ce résultat je doute
fort qu'ils aient pris des gants de
velours mondiaux je crains bien que non
frau darcos qui lui n'a jamais été
accusé de crimes de sang c'est son
ancien associé léonie denis s line
réfugié aujourd'hui en israël que la
justice russe cherche à extrader
retour en 2003 pour leurs copains qui
sous les verrous il s'agit maintenant
pour le kremlin de s'occuper de ioukos
officiellement c'est la justice russe
qui décide de son sort selon la rumeur
c'est igor setchine homme de l'ombre et
conseiller du président
ancien officier du kgb il contrôle aussi
ross neft une modeste compagnies
pétrolières propriété de l'état c'est
insistante rumeur c'est un politologue
proche du pouvoir qui la confirme
quand poutine a compris que ioukos ce
n'est pas seulement une entreprise mais
aussi un parti politique
à ce moment là il a repris le dossier
des mains des libéraux et il a dit
ce n'est plus une affaire économique
c'est devenu politique
il l'a donné à igor setchine qui
coordonne les services de sécurité de
l'état et il lui a dit voilà c'est on
travaille sur doit garantir la
souveraineté de la fédération de russie
et dès le lendemain de l'arrestation de
mireille darc ski c'est alexandre they
merco l'ami fidèle fin connaisseur des
coulisses du pouvoir qui l'a remplacé à
la tête de ioukos c'est lui qui allait
au kremlin pour négocier et sauver la
compagnie
avaient tous l'air effrayé
il me montrait la direction d'un bureau
au quatrième étage celui de notre cher
cette chine et il me disait nous
mangeons toutes les questions se décide
là où on peut discuter avec toi mais
prendre des décisions vous même
transmettre terken c'est tout simplement
pas possible
cette chine contrôler et continue de
contrôler les services de sécurité dans
cet esprit-là
ioukos est donc déclarée en faillite
puis dépecer au cours d'enchères
douteuses trois années d'enchères en
séries avec prête noms mystérieux et
prix de vente bien en dessous du marché
le géant pétrolier change de mains et
crs neft qui s'approprie l'essentiel de
ioukos
roussneft la compagnie pétrolière que
contrôle igor setchine un setchine
convertie aux vertus de l'économie de
marché et qui sort de l'ombre pour la
première réunion publique des
actionnaires en juin 2007
seul le marché peut évaluer
objectivement si une entreprise est
efficace nous avons de nouveaux
principes mais attention à nos
actionnaires minoritaires et le
renforcement de la transparence dans nos
affaires a passé les cinq premières
minutes la presse est prié de quitter la
salle la transparence de rostov a des
limites même si aujourd'hui seules les
télévisions russes contrôlées par l'état
couvre l'événement
de nombreux indicateurs de la compagnie
s'améliore
nulle référence à ioukos il n'est pas
recommandé sur les chaînes de télévision
publiques de rappeler comment roussneft
est devenue la première compagnie
pétrolière du pays
c'est une télé d'état un thème déjà
manié le pétrole une source majeure de
revenus
il y à des sujets sur votre chaîne pour
ne peut pas couvrir il y à l'affairé
ioukos dont il vaut mieux ne pas
s'approcher pourquoi
honnêtement c'est une question à
laquelle je ne peux pas répondre à
gauche chez nous je ne suis pas habilité
à répondre je ne suis qu'une simple
journaliste je ne peux pas commenter
ouvertement les détails
simplement il ya des enjeux politiques
dont je préfère ne pas me mêler
politique qui mois ci au qatar et à
pristina
quatre ans après l'arrestation de
mikhaïl khodorkovski
l'affairé ioukos est toujours une
affaire d'état le pétrole assure 30% du
revenu national une véritable rente pour
le pays et ses dirigeants
je vais à toutes les réunions du
président au kremlin 12 presque chaque
jour sa nullité que l'on parle du
pétrole ou du gaz c'est la seule chose
qui m'intéresse vraiment ce qui lui
importe je te vois tu peux laisser
passer une information et penser que ce
n'est pas important
en fait ça se répercute très vite dans
la vie politique un mois deux mois ou
trois mois plus tard c'est ce qui
détermine toutes les autres questions
touchant
l'énergie au centre de toutes les
préoccupations et pas seulement à moscou
c'est à paris que le président de
rosneft sergueï bogdantchikov vient pour
vanter les mérites de sa compagnie
rosneft le fossoyeur de ioukos le marché
russe promet bogdantchikov aussi
dividendes stabilité perspective plus
une carte maîtresse essentiel en russie
nos liens étroits avec le gouvernement
nous garantissent une croissance durable
grâce à notre participation à des achats
de nouveaux gisements grâce à la
possibilité d'influencer l'opinion des
acteurs pétroliers russes et enfin grâce
à notre capacité à poser sur les lois
majeures dans notre secteur
c'est total la première compagnie
pétrolière française qui invite total
qui tente depuis des années de décrocher
des contrats d'exploitation sur le sol
russe
peu importe l'interlocuteur du causse
ours neft c'est la signature au bas du
contrat qui
nous sommes persévérant nous sommes
convaincus que les opportunités que nous
poursuivons finiront par par déboucher
sur des projets intéressants aujourd'hui
il ya une évolution en russie qui ne
nous paraît pas du tout néfaste à au
développement des activités
est-ce que vous pensez que justement la
redistribution des ressources
pétrolières à savoir la limitation du
causse et la reprise en main
essentiellement par edf c'était une
bonne chose pour la russie je fais pas
de commentaire là dessus
pas de commentaire car aujourd'hui grâce
à la manne pétrolière ce sont les russes
qui dicte les règles du jeu finies les
années 90 et la dépendance aux capitaux
étrangers
roussneft est devenu le gorille du
secteur pétrolier les compagnies
étrangères sont en contact tout le temps
avec elle pour toutes sortes de projets
il n'y a plus beaucoup de réserves
pétrolières dans le monde dans
lesquelles les compagnies
internationales peuvent acquérir des
participations
dont qu'elle revienne à la table même
pour des participations minoritaires
malgré l'affairé ioukos
en fait je ne vois pas de grand
changement c'est pas du tout
sergueï bogdantchikov n'a pas de grandes
difficultés à séduire les investisseurs
occidentaux aujourd'hui proche neft joue
dans la cour des grands
on a échangé des informations des
contacts ça fait aussi partie du
business même dans le pétrole
un peu plus tard on apprendra que total
et rosneft ont signé des accords portant
sur près de 2 milliards de dollars un
montant encore modeste dans l'univers du
pétrole mais plein de perspectives
retour à moscou
cette fois dans les rangs de
l'opposition au kremlin
fowler costi n'est certes pas devenu une
icône mais pour une minorité de russes
il est quand même une victime symbolique
de l'arbitraire du pouvoir
et c'est cet arbitraire que combat
l'autre russie un tout jeune parti
d'opposition
sur le devant de la scène il y a le très
médiatique garry kasparov ancien
champion du monde d'échecs en retrait
le discret organisateurs alexandre au
soft sauf ancien président de la
fondation de rôdeur cofsky russie
ouverte
présent lui aussi le député alex hayes
rhonda aux rough fidèle soldat de rôdeur
cofsky il dresse un portrait du candidat
idéal portrait qui ressemble beaucoup à
l'image qu'il a de son ancien patron
il ne doit pas seulement avoir réussi
sur le plan professionnel il doit savoir
aussi dirigé une structure d'état
rendent complexe il doit être audacieux
ça c'est indispensable aujourd'hui le
pouvoir casse les gens et leur fait
courber l'échiné
pour ces deux partisans de khodorkovski
aucun doute l'ancien oligarque aurait pu
avoir un destin national
c'est une personne qui possède une très
grande intelligence
et une énergie immense
et ce qui nous serait vraiment utile ce
sont ses talents et son expérience
d'organisateur c'est ce qui nous manque
en cela nous sentons sont absents dont
aujourd'hui on commence à choisir notre
candidat d'opposition pour la
présidentielle il est évident que s'il
était en liberté il serait l'un d'entre
eux aujourd'hui et je ne cache pas que
c'est lui que je soutiendrai
huit mois avant les élections de mars
2008 l'autre russie n'a toujours pas de
candidat
dehors les mouvements de jeunesse de
vladimir poutine prêche la bonne parole
et d into peuple les ennemis de la
patrie et l'ex oligarque products qui
est l'une de leurs cibles préférées
rogers cup ch'ti par exemple s'il avait
vendu ioukos la plus grande compagnie
pétrolière russe aux états unis et bien
cela aurait puisé 70% de notre pétrole
ça représente des sommes énormes c'est
bien plus que les revenus de la
prostitution et des ventes d'armes
réunis en avait un pays immense il s'est
désintégré
il y avait l'urss unis et puissante
tant qu'on reste les propriétaires de
notre pétrole on peut dicter nos règles
nous en sommes les maîtres si les
etats-unis mettaient la main dessus ils
nous piétinent ray on prépare la
nouvelle génération pour le pouvoir et
poutine nous soutient dans ce projet ce
sont des gens comme robert cox qui
enfonce la situation et qu'ils essaient
de s'engraisser avec les ressources de
notre pays ce qui n'a pas eu de chance
il est tombé sur poutine poutine a
réussi à l'arrêter à temps grâce à son
expérience dans les services
sursaut nationaliste vocabulaire de
guerre froide nous sommes aux antipodes
des discours de l'ancien oligarque de
recy se font face et ne s'écoute pas
combien on vous a payé pour faire cette
provocation
pas un kopeck nous est venus ici par
conviction vous êtes un ennemi de la
russie vous êtes un an et demi d'arrêt
ces
pillards sans vergogne ou héros de la
russie moderne luttes de pouvoir ou
conflits de valeurs l'oligarque est au
centre de ces interrogations
le citoyen re darcos qui lui purge sa
peine à 5000 kilomètres de là au gré des
remises de peine il aurait pu sortir en
2007 mais voilà la justice ruse romain